we've got gun battles we've got fire  burns we've got a big car crash  getting dirty it's really exciting the  scope of the movie is much much bigger  than we've ever done before we're really  lucky on this film because we have some  amazing actors that are all willing to  do their own action one of my favorites  is the stairwell fight that we have with  Ilan I like being the tense so for me to  be able to get in there to get my heart  beat getting those adrenaline glands  going that's been cool this is my first  time shooting a gun and having to fire  at someone was crazy  this is my first time being able to do  this much action the fans I would say we  want more purging so we definitely  deliver on this movie more than we have  ever before  you